اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم خمسه شهداء بينهم طفل
واكثر من 90 مصابا في اقتحام اسرائيلي
لمخيم جنين استخدمت فيه المروحيات للمره
الاولى منذ اكثر من 20 عاما جيش الاحتلال
يعلن اصابه سبعه من جنوده احدهم في حاله
خطره ويعلن سحب 5 اليات عسكريه من اطراف
المخيم اعطبتها فصائل فلسطينيه والمقاومه
تتواعد باستخدام اسلحه مفاجئه اذا استمرت
عمليات الاحتلال خلال اجتماع دولي بشان
الاستجابه الطارئه للازمه في السودان قطر
والرياض تتعهدان بتقديم ملايين دولارات
لدعم السودان وجوتيرش يصف الوضع هناك
بالمقلق والخارجيه السودانيه ترفض دعوه
كيمياء الى اجتماع لرباعيه الايجاد بشان
الازمه في ختام زيارته لبيجين وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي يؤكد ان هناك اتفاقا مع
الصينيين على الحاجه لاستقرار العلاقات
بين الطرفين يؤكد التزام بلاده بمبدا
الصين والرئيس الصيني يؤكد احراز تقدم في
المحادثات بين البلدين
للمره الاولى في تاريخه منتخب اسبانيا
يتوج بلقب دوري الامم الاوروبيه لكره
القدم عقب فوزه بركلات الترجيح على منتخب
كرواتيا في المباراه النهائيه للمسابقه
القاريه التي اقيمت على ملعب بينوردا
بمدينه روتردام الهولنديه الى اللقاء